For quadratic inequalities, we can show the solution in one of two ways. On a
number line, we know that these values satisfy the inequality and these values
do as well. We use parentheses at x equals negative 3 and x equals, 4 since we
know these numbers make the equation equal to 0. These two numbers would not be
part of the solution set. The other way we can write our solution set is in
interval notation. Keep in mind, since we have two non-overlapping regions,
we'll need to use the union symbol in between the two intervals. What I want
you to do is to fill in each of these boxes using the correct interval
notation. Be sure to use parenthesis or brackets and include the infinity
symbol or the numbers as necessary. Good luck.